okay I am currently in the HS rapid
arena rapid shield arena it's a six hour
long tournament know it's an eight hour
long tournament but there's six hours
left
I'm joining late I'm not gonna play the
full thing or even a small fraction I'm
going to play a very small fraction
let's play you four
you know hold off from Berzerk Inge
against the lower e the players I'll try
and play more aggressively if he plays
Quinn 85 I'll play b4 Oh what is with my
trackpad okay let's not mess up too
early
this is a fun gambit
thanks for the cheer rufus doofus the
whole point of this gambit is to give
away a pawn to accelerate development to
get some initiative he's thinking here
which is a good sign not the most common
gambit against the Scandinavian hello to
everyone in the chats
hello jacksie hello Africa well Nathan
hello toilet
Karm our twitch s Rufus Davis hero
rook p1 is most common rook be ones
logical but there's a very specific trap
that he's not going to fall into 9a six
is a decent move maybe after the game I
can show the trap I was hoping for but
for now let's just develop
Bishop d7
normally when the night gets kicked it
should go to d4
considering a three but that could walk
into Queenie for
well a three
for
play Bishop e2 he takes on b5 let's play
Knight e4
unleashing my bishop
as Queens still awkward on b4 to
slightly unusual position
actually I went over this in a YouTube
video there's like one of my very first
instructional videos on my channel I
think it's something that's some title
like how to crush the Scandinavian
defense
so popular video though
so II six
thinking that maybe he could have
lady five
now the question is how do I complete
development the c3 is interesting
53
I've always considered taking on a six
because if I play Bishop d3 is Knight c5
so maybe I play Bishop e2 or maybe I
start with c3
let's start with c3 because I'm not sure
where his Queen is going to to move I
guess not allow this Bishop a4 the or
Queen a4
could be weird
to pay for queening e - I'll go for it
I don't mind weird positions thanks for
the host Nathan I'm looking I look
shining I guess I'll take that is a good
thing
I see about community gift subs I have
no idea what that is and no I did not
see anything about it but it sounds
interesting I like gifts and I like
community
I like subs like all of those things
a messy Marvin thanks for the sub okay
Queen b6 let's just play Bishop d3 and
now if you play the knight c5 I can
retreat and then I'll have it be one
coming
yeah there are many benefits to c3 which
I didn't really acknowledge
few seconds ago
let's play rugby one first I put c3 it
opens up the diagonal for the bishop it
gives me a retreat square it supports
the night all-around multi-purpose move
now as Queen is really awkward because
when it moves I can take b7
but then he has 95
so
probably hold off
I'm not worried about a two
Brook tb7 Knight c5
he doesn't work let's just castle just
about completed with development
he's still underdeveloped be7 is still
hanging still a weird position okay he
goes up another pond
I can't imagine this is good for black
maybe it's playable
so I don't see any immediate way to trap
the Queen
I mean I do want to take on b7 and then
Knights e5
maybe rugby to
and I went back upon
Lucy moody thanks for the sub so rooked
ap7 night c5 rook be to Queen moves I
retreat to c2
um also plain ip3 immediately my p3 has
a threat of rook a1 just not sure about
93 Bishop a4
I'm gonna take on b7 so I'm still down
upon
okay night c5-b to
like I have compensation
and with nine on c5 I would like to
somehow get my pawn to d4 as soon as
possible
so what's probably gonna happen he's
probably gonna play Queen 85 I'll play
Bishop c2 and then have to find a square
for my knight
maybe I can consider Knight d5
get really weird it's probably just bad
for whites
especially queen 85 defense e7
so after Queen 85 was he thinking about
maybe he's considering Queen a4
you
he plays I'll have an option of Bishop
c2 or even Bishop to b5
Bishop e5 actually looks attractive as
well
the bishops keep some initiative maybe
infiltrate the c6 square green d5 forgot
that was a legal move
I'm Bishop b5 is still an option
Canada move Knight b5 is now looking
attractive too
it's wrong
there should be one idea bishop a -
there's a bunch of candidate moves
there's not too much time to think
though
I'm just gonna go with intuition play
Bishop b5 because if we trade bishops I
keep initiative
and meanwhile I might want to play c4 I
might want to just take
then something like b5 or even I have
ideas of rook e1 to e5 as Queen is such
a target fianchetto thanks for the auto
host
so he plays c6 it's logical
I could play C for a year
in Queen d6 I'm getting very weird c4
Queen b6 my bishop is a bit stuck
it's my bishop is stuck regardless I
you play Bishop a4 along some trade
I'm just down upon
I could play this would be too
very soon I'll start moving quicker
let's play
yeah let's play this his - active it's
okay if he trades it off
I'll probably focus very soon on this
idea I just have to watch out for 93
because that could be irritating I might
have some idea of playing c4 so drive
the Queen away from defending c6
hello lemon chief
hello no joke
is so many people here
wait did I miss no see five years or I
have a night be five ninety five would
be a triple fork so this is what I'm
banking on
and how does he stop it and he can play
like rook c8 or Bishop d6
but the goal is to keep initiative make
him think got him low on time
if he plays rook c8 maybe I play Queen
at 4 or maybe I just take upon
and I finally removed everything from
these squares like I have d4 coming soon
too
Queen c6 I don't think this is good
because 95
Queen z6 looks good because he creates
the battery but he walks into a fork and
now now his queen has to move again and
he can't move back just moved to c8 or
b7
b7
okay it's weird because my night is
still pinned on b5 but maybe I can play
like Knight c4
threatening the fork
I play
I could take
with Knights
and then queen f4
actually if he takes with Queen I of
night c7 and when he takes with night I
live Queen I for threatening night c7
keeping the initiative if he plays ePHI
I'll play rook e1 and then some kind of
d4 idea
that's hard for him to defend in square
G five might be forced
it's Kim Dao I just take on a seven
so let's play rookie one
you
so I'm not sure how much I'm getting
here because
this yeah and if I had like two moves in
a row I would love love to take on a and
play tonight c7 but he's about to Castle
so maybe I sack
maybe I just play rook take e5
the problem is ripped 8590 q5 quintile
out of castle and a q7 rookie Yates
and that would be bad
that would be very bad
you
so okay
to be down upon
where's my comp
I'll go for this these pawns are targets
I'll probably go for d4 very soon
soon a six is coming
realizing Queen c4 was probably in a
state because my knight wants to be on
c4
I'm struggling
let's play okay let's
okay - lets play quicker -
Gotham chess
I said privyet earlier and I'm not
fluent in Russian know how you got that
I know very little Russian you know I
need pani mayapur risky ok 93
this is gonna require some positional
maneuvering d5 is a whole maybe some day
I'll I'll move my queen i'll put upon
the sea for it and just land a knight on
d5 okay let's start the maneuvering
attack with tempo 93 93 is a nice square
but access to many more nice squares
passed ball 99 it's going well enjoying
st. Louis such a great chess atmosphere
environments
about to be an even better chess
atmosphere starting what's today today's
Thursday starting in two days is a st.
Louis rapid and blitz
it's going to be exciting to watch not
as exciting as last year though
the whole kasparov thing but maybe
as exciting as this position especially
after 95 pass Pau and thanks for the
slug yeah 95 is a fork I think I'm
officially about to be a material unless
I'm missing something unless you can
play something like this but then I can
take the rook and defend the Queen
and think I'm just winning in exchange
the thing is I don't really want to
trade off my night but I think I mean I
mean it makes sense I win
can win the exchange I am an ape on
unless he I guess he could
more trades now all the pawns are weak
take more stuff
Sandra Mason coming from YouTube nice I
feel like a lot of people come from
YouTube it's just a breeding ground for
for new viewers rook d6
time is good material is good my King
has left
yeah I just want to create more open
files this is a pawn sack I want to get
the bishop to a three
somehow orchestrate some checkmate
there's lots of nice alignment here
work is coming
pin combined with the fork there's a
nice one of the nicest tactics which I
like to call the pork let's put the root
there
okay you played well I would say he's
underrated he find it off some early
compensation just to show the viewers if
you would like something really
aggressive to play against Scandinavian
before is an interesting move and the
main trap which I did show in another
video is normally black will play Queen
a5 as we see the most popular move at
least on me chess so Queen a5 Bishop to
c4 and then the amazing thing is the
most popular move for her black in this
position is just a tragic blunder most
people play c6 and then they walk into
this this beautiful geometrical tactic
but should take f7 and queen h5 and
white usually wins the Queen after g6
and 96 check if flack wanted to not lose
the Queen he could play King of 6 but
then Bishop b2 check and Queen take e5 f
king of 796 king g6 white is having fun
anyway the game went a bit differently
oh wow so the that's interesting I
didn't realize they update the database
so quickly
as I've never seen
did we just make some updates because I
have like I know that games getting the
database eventually I didn't know it was
like instance that's nice to know
yeah I took some work there black was
probably better even around even around
here black should be better I would say
like - points three or minus 0.4 let's
check with stockfish
just equal maybe it's better sock fish
has no clue whenever it's zero it's just
stock fish is confused okay
so equal chances well I have pending
challenges I think I'm gonna just go
back to the tournament play a few more
games maybe later I'll take challenges
but for now I'll play max let's go
you
well if I'm vegan
the context is with that comment but
flank our foes thank you for the follow
I still don't understand I am NOT vegan
I do admire vegans oh I do like vegan
food okay we have a four nights
you
or night Scotch haven't played against
us in a while
this brings back a lot of nostalgia from
childhood because I used to play this
fair for both sides
and usually black get some nice equality
get some position to try and play for a
win
can I do some can I do in English at
some points at first I thought you meant
the language but now realizing you mean
c4 and move on yeah I could play in
English I enjoy playing English
Oh pork I mean you can still execute a
pork if you're a vegan you just have to
do it on the chess board
he's thinking here which is a good sign
because I'm attacking upon
and I think there's only one good move
for a white in this position which I'm
not going to say because you might be
watching the flight doesn't play the
best move I'm not sure with the second
best move is
yeah this is the best move very very
nice job I'm remembering was there a
move
I'm remembering there's a tricky line I
kind of regret that I forgot about it
because I probably would have played
that there's a move here and they take
e4 which is actually interesting for
black but too late let's play d5 and
I'll go into just a mainline
now I think there's two moves for light
between this and this most people do
this I'll do this
have I played Magnus I've been asked
this question before an answer is yes
but not in chess I played Magnus in
soccer and basketball he's a pretty good
athletes age 3 confuses me
not sure why he played h3 just continue
c6 is a normal move
you
you
most of the times white will do this and
this I guess sometimes h3 is played to
prevent Bishop g4
I think this line was played at the the
US Championships between Ray Robson and
Nakamura and Ray just wanted some quick
draw so he played this as whites but he
didn't play h3 and he didn't play Bishop
d2 he played a lot more aggressively the
bishop usually retreats to to d6 and
wait setup is a little bit passive here
it's all gonna be a fight they repeat
use an easy move to play with tempo
certainement SC just moved to Chicago
I'm not in Chicago right now but if
you're if you're a chess player and you
live in Chicago there's a good number of
tournaments to play and chess scene is
uh is pretty nice there
so what to do
probably developed the bishop just
played Bishop e6
over defend the pawn so someday I want
to play c5
not sir King thanks for the follow
okay
I'm trying to understand what's going on
in this position I mean why it's just
putting his pieces on squares but I
don't know if they're doing anything I
know if my pieces are doing anything
either like we're both very solid
I feel like c5 should be played if I
want to make progress
considering playing h6 as well or even
some maneuver like Knight d7 95
which is interesting 97 allows queen h5
but then I have g6
you play h6 first
and then just see what he does I'm very
curious actually I just want you to want
to see what he does here
okay 92 so he has some intention of
flying 9f for 93
I guess that's the standard idea and
maybe he wants to get the bishop hair so
maybe I'll maneuver my night too and
maybe we'll both hit the bishop hair
which would mean neither of us gets the
bishop pair so 97 94 95
yeah let's go for that
and objectively I feel like it's still
equal
okay what's this threat is ideally I
would like to just move back but maybe I
can just take because I'm his Knights
pinned yeah let's take Queen take Wow
with the pre move
okay now I'm gonna play Queen f6 and the
idea is when he takes I'll take with
pawn and then if he plays Bishop c3 I
play e5 that should be a nice position
then maybe you can play f4
okay Bishop c3d5f1 on I could play e4
taketake
that loan
humans a pack but then f4 would be weak
let's go for it
why not BB for Bishop before at what
point I don't think there is ever Bishop
before unless earlier I like my bishop
on d6 it's closer to the center
lemon chief asking could he play tonight
take e6 after 95 no because I take with
the queen with check very important ok
so he plays rookie to
I'm considering e4 here
be8 looks very normal to let's play
trippy AIDS
just a simple quick move
now there's lots of lots of focus on the
e5 pawn
I should probably unpin it pickled pawn
thanks for the hundred bits kind of
drawn to this move Queen f4
this if he plays g3 I'm okay with that
I am allowing Queen g6 though
you
when g6 is actually really not in Queen
I for Queen g6 and I can't play E for
cos he mates me
maybe I play rook e6 first
let's do it rookie six simply improving
I would like to play like Queen afore
and perfect queen g6 and someday play e4
and maybe if I really want to defend my
pawn another time I could play rook fe8
but I just don't want to be to commit
Allah before and d4 are both possible
moves but I would like to stay flexible
they can think
it's another position I'm not sure
he's going to do
are just
they're on decent squared is but I don't
think they're doing too much
I also have ideas of Bishop c5
I could trade the e-pawn for the Athlon
you
there should be two outs
go
for
you could take on f6 and that would be
bad okay let's play this
I was expecting g3 McQueen III
so move
and he's attacking 87
so I could play Queen f7 I'm just gonna
keep all the all the tension don't want
to commit don't want to trade queens too
early
you
you
especially situations like this I would
rather him just think
rather than give him easy options c4 is
interesting because now if I play d4 he
can take because of the pin
so I think now it's time to play e4 even
though this opens our diagonal it it
just leaves the pawn on light squares so
it makes a bishop happy
has ideas of Bishop to f4 which looks
really attractive here
you
Queen c3 was forest
now I'll go back my Bishop is effective
from far away
and in Korea for it looks like a cheapo
but I think it's a it's just a strong
move
I also have ideas over at g6 like
actually all my pieces will be
thing attack the kingside in some way
which is what I want in the position
like this
play Lee
Queen áfourá g3 and then rep g6
so you plays g3 immediately
okay let's start with rook g6
I'm over defending the g7 pawns so now I
might want to play Queen f5 next he
wants to trade which is very logical
I can't avoid the traded bishops so I'm
gonna play Queen f5 we'll trade on b8
and then
try and keep the attack and he's going
to play king h2 will go for h5 h4
you
and the porn thing is to keep the time
advantage
and start with h5
weenie three so he's allowing h4
you
I'm just going to be safe
play restrictive
you can infiltrate the C file but then
I'll put my king on each 7h for let's
play rook f7
and this is a backwards pawn I can
triple up against it
have I ever played poker
I've played poker
for the first time in a casino in Vegas
what just happened
toilet noggin gifting everyone subs how
did he okay so this I guess this is a
community sub thing Thank You toilet
noggin I was unexpected
um let's try not to get distracted just
because sounds are happening my time is
running low
I think seems like blocks should be on
the verge of winning this position
how do I do it
g4
you
sounds okay I think I can play queen g4
because he's tied down to F 2 the
problem is I don't see the threat here
of course there's ideas of g5 but that
might be that could be very risky I'll
play a move like g5 if he has like less
than 30 seconds left
King ruck g6
I'll start with Queen f3
you
ooh now III III he takes his queen
though
you
I play Queen f5 this is a stage where
I'm just going to try and dance around
and get my time advantage back and maybe
somehow hypnotize him
to win this pawn
not lose this fun
it's a difficult goal maybe I can play
Queen h3 with the threat of rook take
jisuk gg3
that would be a maiden to threat
actually
I'll see if he notices is he going to
see it
mmm he kind of saw it
three I think this is crushing Queenie -
where's my mate
tick g3 take G 3 root 2 G 3 king F 2
the Queen I could also just take on each
border
maybe I'll just take on h4
right nothing
now I'm I'm still threatening rook take
g3
Brook take g3 has to be good here
at the very least I went his queen
the very most I checked made him
you
yeah this is meat somehow right queen h1
- Queen h2 King II one
rook Jiwan queen f1 queen g3 Keaney -
Queen f3 king e1 then I take on f1 with
me except he has work f2 there but if
rook F to cook have to maybe I can play
III and he's just pinned
calculating
just win the queen
oh maybe I just forgot that he couldn't
that oh he just resigns think he should
play on
attacking my queen I mean it's much
better for black but okay interesting
game haven't played that variation in a
while it took some work there to break
through
could I play rook to e3 instead of Queen
h3 instead of queen h3o in this position
probably
I was just so excited to play Queen h3
with the threat of made in two but rook
take g3 winds upon and probably more I
mean take f1 king h2
I mean this should be good for black
maybe just Rick at five
anyway interesting game there is a
variation I'm curious about because I
don't think I ever looked into it too
closely it's this move Knight takes e4
which scores well for lack according to
Lee chess by the after night a key for
Queen e7
I'm actually not sure why this is bad
we'll have to analyze this a different
time maybe I'll go back or maybe I'll
accept to challenge anyone challenging
me
hmmm let's just go back we'll say play
someone completely random
I broke the top 500 it's an
accomplishment
any chess books and recommendations
that's because something with the
plug-in broke I have to fix that I'll
try and fix that at some point
play this opening again also I don't
think I gave a proper thank you to all
the subs but thank you all the suds that
were gifted by toilet noggin and a
special thank you to Toyota noggin
okay I'm playing a 1244 so I'm gonna try
and win this game as quickly as possible
well we have another four nights if he
plays a four night scotch I'll play that
90 key for a move
most people at least most new players
play Bishop c4 year and then that walks
into some some tricks
you
place
you
Oh what were the book recommendations
the art of learning by Josh Waitzkin
it's a great book what else
I mean recently I've discovered some new
books which I think are are great
actually
another classic is Jeff Coakley's
strategy for weight
chess strategy for kids or something
like that by Jeff Coakley it's a great
book
even for adults it's one of the best
book I think for newer players like
anyone below 1200 I think should have
worked through that book another series
of books which I can recommend our chest
steps which are they're very popular in
Europe there's like six books in the
series and they're all work with work
books but they're they're great at
training pattern recognition
another book is 100 n games you must
know there's something along those lines
it's a good book
what else can I recommend
I'll work on putting together the list
put that on my to-do list maybe even buy
today
okay so he's falling for the center for
a trick which is a Bishop III is not the
best move because he's not winning back
the pawn his knight has to retreat if he
wants to save the Knights this is
already very sad for white
50 mates you must know I've never heard
of that book but sounds interesting
Apple has I I heard chasuble has like a
good number of books in there their
digital format I've heard great feedback
from everyone who who use accessible
what did he play oh he played Knight g5
thank you very much
the sky's generous
so generous
as generous as toilet noggin
I'm up to pawns in a piece what's the
quickest way to victory Bishop g4 or
maybe Bishop got called a bishop each
three
you
and after he plays this she's probably
the
try all of this move this is hard to
defend for whites even if he finds the
best moves
you
you
also um I need new emotes I've forgotten
to like do an e mode screen where I make
new emotes but I think I can make like 2
or 3 new ones so I will take suggestions
also
I think what's a follower account but I
was gonna do something special for 3,000
followers and it might happen the stream
thank you for the rook
before people 8c3 I'll take
you
he's not gonna resign he's gonna play on
until Nate's
so after somehow made him I don't want
to trade Queens but I might have to
and chess player thanks for the sub
what to do
okay I guess I'll trade Queens and then
I'll queenside castle and get the D file
maybe I'll even sack of bishop
just get my knight to be for let's do it
let's put it working d3
oh that sub was gifted by toilet huggin
so now it's a competition who's more
generous toilet noggin my opponent
it all depends if my father takes the
bishop
I guess I want him to take
[ __ ] though
how else do i mate I could bring the
rook to d8
maybe the quickest way is to chase away
this bishop or maybe hole maybe he'll
just give it to me
rook take t2
I'll bonobo thanks for the follow
another idea here we're playing III and
Bishop f5
there should be some
some sort of discovery actually III
Bishop f5 and rook takes III would be
mates
double-check mates
the goal
I didn't need to play
play Bishop f5 and then III
I'm expecting I'm expecting this but I
guess I I can expect anything here
you
expected correctly okay now I'll do this
and hopefully he'll see that there's a
pin and I'll take with pawn allowing me
this
if he doesn't see that there's a pin I
guess I'll take
actually if he takes with Bishop I take
with rook Bishop about five is made in
one threat
you
so let's say King their unexpected
let's just take with check
so I don't think I'll get my fancy so
it's
I'll get something
the threat is this and this Bishop c2 is
a good move
[Music]
this is gonna prolong the game
to
okay let's just play wreck a fire rook
f3 defending our five
yeah I've been streaming for
and our
I'm probably a stream for another like
45 minutes if I can stay awake
I should probably get some caffeinated
tea because this is like herbal tea and
it just puts me to sleep not the best
thing to have in the morning okay but
let's try and meet contriving from the
last 22 moves rookie 2 and rookie 1 is a
plan
or this is a plan
hero is leaving by hero this is probably
the point in the game where I can take
questions like if people have questions
I can try and answer its I'd rather try
and provide value by not focusing too
much on this game let's take another
pawn
push pawns maybe I can push all my pawns
how many subs I have
I actually don't know that there should
be like a sub count command or something
I would think
you
I think the quickest way to win is to
promote upon make a queen forget about
the night it's going to take on D to
take longer to promote upon what opening
do I recommend for a white against the
classical Dutch what is a classical
Dutch is that at 5 e 6 Bishop e7
and oh he resigns good game tweets food
a tough game
just a lesson next time if you're white
don't play Bishop c4 play Bishop b5 or D
for real quick classical Dutch d4 f5 I
can recommend there's a game a Cobian
trick goob off starting with Knight c3
you see if I can find this real quick a
Cobian try gue Bob Dutch
you
[Music]
that starts with Knight c3 and it's just
such a great game yeah here it is
how can I share this with people I'll
just share the chess games comlink but
it's such a great game like echo beam
just gets a strong queenside attack and
I think you can use that game as kind of
a skeleton for your your opening
preparation so there you go chat
is a Berlin the best defense against the
Spanish um that's arguable Berlin is
certainly popular right I don't really
think it's a an effective opening
against it's like at the lower levels
like sub master level feel like there's
better other options for black
mewls of berlin has like very deep
strategical ideas which takes some time
to understand because the resulting
position at least in the mainline is
passive for black and black has to
understand how to play it with not too
much space
your next game as white a Sicilian well
I'll play e4 but okay he plays a five so
all I wanted to play the Spanish but too
late so let's play let's play d4 here
most aggressive moves most aggressive
move to join my dis court you can just
you should be able to just click the
link you might need the app if you're on
your phone let's play Knight to c3
we have a Philidor will play this line
with Bishop to f4 and then Queen d2 in
Castle queenside
I'm trying to remember there's a game
there's a game between hammer and xun
hammer I think actually Castle kingside
hammer let's play Bishop you two
you had some crazy idea like 9f5 knife
f5 hello axe villager good to see you
back
long time no see
I think this time is more friendly for
the European viewers
cuz
here up I could take on you seven let's
take on you seven now it looks weird to
trail off such an active night for the
passive Bishop but the point is now that
now d6 is pretty weak and I get the
bishop pair
six is just a backwards pond
so I'm gonna focus on positional chess
and go for Cal slating f3 maybe at some
point I'll play Knight d5 probably put
the rook on you on
you
9h five
let's play Bishop g5
because after f6 is Knight is kind of
stuck I can go back and I think I'm just
threatening g4 here just to trap the
night so he has to do something weird
are they like g6
seven
you
I don't think I'll play g4 right away
I'm gonna play b3 first preventing any
sort of like night c4 Bishop c4 e6 so
quickly
okay now I'll go for this and then I'm
going to play a ch3
like after night g7 h3 the idea is to
expand with F for keeping G for defended
I just want to chase this neither way
gain more space
he runs away without me attacking him
it's all gain space anyway I'll put the
bishop on f3
slowly but surely expands
okay so he wants to put the bishop on b7
this allows me to play 95
and now the amazing thing is I don't
think his queen had any good square
because it was tied down to f6 and
Queenie six-foot has walked into Knight
c7 this walks into a fork
now White's just winning the Queen that
was tough
that's what happens when you have space
you have good pieces
yeah the Queen has no we're great to go
I think Bishop e6 was just a mistake
very careful here okay if I'm on the
receiving end of the Royal apes' do I
play the carries defense
what's the carries defense
as carries
or is that something else I admit I
don't know what the carries defenses
okay back to tournaments I am getting
tired
like into any rating points I've played
much lower a player I don't think I've
gained any rating points
yeah live from the 850 I try and be
instructive that's one of the main goals
of doing this but sometimes I just got
distracted okay so I'm on the verge of
breaking top 212 points first place has
80 points so I don't think I'm gonna
make a running for for first place yeah
the key to this tournament if you want
to like win it you have to buzzer let's
play another another key for opening
Alec I'm I was going over this other day
and I was showing I was showing a funny
in line let's see if we get into it I'm
gonna play d4 please take on b2 let's
have some fun
it's about to happen this is a fun line
I think it's about equal please take the
rook
could be boring and take on g7
he's thinking it's probably new for him
this is very rare line but I think it's
a quickest opening in chess where both
sides yet
another queen if I move six we could uh
I move seven me both promotes all he's
so boring who's ready to have some fun
there
I will say this is maybe already not the
best for white
now I have to figure things out I mean
Bishop e5 I would like to play it but
then he have Queen a5 threats he would
just play tonight c6 and then behind
Queen a5 so c5 is interesting
because there is pressure
you
he's threatening to win upon
I could play c3 and make the bishop sad
or I could just play Bishop b5
six I just take
you
and then 92
you
yeah this is just better for luck I'm
gonna play Bishop b5
you
good move taketake 92
I see three as well
you
well if I play d5
probably too crazy his queen 85 could
hurt me
wait a minute d5 when if
- yeah he just he takes but then I take
is d5 playable here
d5 bishop take b2
six then Qin a five
I don't think it works but I don't know
exactly why I'm gonna analyze it after
the game I think I'll just play
for this line not thrilled about this
because he's getting the bishop hair in
a pretty open position
you disconnected
during while he was taking some time to
recapture
well that's unfortunate okay he's back
let's play 92
you
to be under pressure so the caries
variation is whatever this image is of
97
I don't think I've actually seen that
before at least I haven't seen it
recently okay I was more scared of
Bishop a6 there so
this is actually comforting because I
would be happy to go into some hanging
and game where we both uh we trade
Queens
and snake vs. bishop very playable
I don't
against weaker players because I'm not
too concerned about tournament points I
just want to play some decent quality
games and I think at least from the
feedback that I've heard viewers prefer
slower games where I actually explain my
thoughts
everyone might be five is a move
five
to it
you
expecting some kind of like rook b8 but
I can take on your seven
I get strapped
bullet tournment please while I'm
playing with a trackpad so
well it would be difficult
maybe for another stream though I
haven't played too much bullet in a
while
King g7 Wow
you
well
I mean my rooks want to
to access open files so he'll play keen
c6 and I'll play Knight to c3
and then I would like to get another
rook to e1 and these are my files
I used to be really fast with the
trackpad and then I got a new laptop
with a slightly different feeling
trackpad and I'm not as fast with it
so then I got a mouse the mouse I'm
decent with it rook b8 let's play rook
e1
threatening the pawn hmm
you
you
you'll go for a rookie five positions
like this you really have to identify
and target the weaknesses c5 is a a very
clear weakness because 94 could come
there's also ideas of f4 f5 cousin
Bishop is kind of pinned to the pawn to
rook before makes sense he's preventing
a4 and he wants to double up
if I play 94
Roxy for I'd be weird
like 94
you
yeah ninety-four Brooksie for
eighty-five
94c for rook c5 check
v6
go for it
you
there's not too many ways to save the
pond
and if you play see for them the bishop
is kind of blocked I mean he could take
on a two but then I have my choice of
which pawn to win he does take on a two
okay
I take on c5 then he plays King b6 and
my Knights attacks
one is coming wait this is scary
rook takes e5 King b6
this could be bad actually
because rook b1 is such a big threat
ouch
I live Knight takes e5 Knight takes e5
rook e1 in d2 and then I have 93 if
necessary
so Knight takes e5 fp1 King dtft 1893
if Knight takes e5 he plays f6 I just
moved to like h5
93 should save me
okay so as a tray the pawns still equal
material
my g3 is such a
move assuming I'm not overlooking
anything
and these pawns are
most solid plans never fly f6
six is logical but I mean rec age five
just might help me
and as soon as I get the chance I want
93
you
I have to watch out for time to know
what happened to my time
okay rook h5
you might play e5 993
I also have to watch out for my rooks
both peeing on light squares and him
having a light square bishop
okay
still looks okay and can trade
ooh bishop
I didn't see that
crushing me wow what a move I didn't see
that at all because Bishop g6 is coming
a
strong
well I would like to fight I'm losing a
night
ouch bishop g6 so I think the plan is to
bring the rook setta
this is so sad I'd bring the rook to f3
but then he has his Bishop h5
my loser exchange
okay I'll give him the choice I'm try
and make him think here whether he wants
to take the night or take the rook he
takes a night and now I'll have some
checks
now the backwards bishop move easy to
overlook
I have a passed pawn also he just gave
me a pawn
see too
you
okay
well if we trade off all the plants
draw but I don't think that's going to
happen given his technique so far let's
play rock a3
try
maybe work f3
it's defending of too
you have to play quicker
I think the idea is to play h4 g3 and to
be solid maybe even g4 though
sophomore pons
that was a really good move
or was it
we'll find out
still fighting
you
I have f3 always playoff three
work
he's winning all my pawns
so white is still dead lost
but I don't
much hope but I'm not going to resign
because miracles happen sometimes
Oh king of
he was really bad King f3 I resign the
hope is to somehow like get a sale
matric rogue a one should have been
played so what was my blunder I was
allowing f6 or it was taking on c5 maybe
now that was a nice combination by him
he could have even played Bishop f7 here
it's very similar strong move so maybe
it was allowing this shift take a to
like maybe I should play a three first
a good game I'm
still disappointed he didn't go into the
this
for queens line
oh you know what okay I'll mod toilet
noggin
congratulations toilet noggin 99 right
now nightbot should not not obstruct you
in any way
wait a minute
oh if he takes on c1 and makes a queen
and I can take on h8 and make a queen it
would be funny
so from this position yeah I think c5 is
a good move
didn't see anything better I thought he
was going to play Bishop a6 here
would have been effective but yeah my
pieces got awkward and his bishop was a
good piece bishop f7
good game what to do do i play someone
we'll finish off with a game against a
viewer assuming this is a viewer
the quickest time control three plus two
and we'll try and end on a happy note
he's still here
okay he's here I want to play an
exchange Roy just play knight c6 yes now
play a six
yes okay this is just for toilet noggin
and we're going to Castle right goslings
main line
and we'll see you we'll see what he does
I used to play this in childhood and
this is just such a simple decent
opening if I just plays g4 next
and there's actually a really important
move by has to know if he's playing
Essex toilet noggin with ten thousand
bits is this real-life wow I should play
the exchange Roy in water often Thank
You toilet noggin I was gonna say that
block black has to know that after take
take c5 is a move to be played well what
is 97 I can win upon this is a free pawn
I think it was unexpected more
unexpected than 97 okay now I'll take
here
and like usually the idea with the
exchange Spanish is white has like the
the four on three on the kingside and
black has four on three on the queenside
but there's a double pawn so
what was I going to say so it's easier
to for a white to make a pass pawn but
in this case now I'm just up I'm up it's
at only one pawn
I'm only up one pond but it feels like
more
100 bits of from hero his attempt at
beating toilet noggin
what a bit war okay so if he takes on
that six I will
well also i have triple pawns i'm one
capture away from having quadruple puns
is so tempting
I don't know if it's the best move
because he plays rook g8
I'll be the best move and then I'll just
keep pushing pawns put the bishop on s6
and probably put the pawn on e5
and this defends this defends us this
defends everything and then the plan one
plan is rook d7 another plan is Knight
g5 my chief I would be mate I'd be a
nice mate more bits related something
thanks for the bits ok I want to play 94
which Forks a bishop and forks checkmate
but he takes which I completely forgot
about I can still play this
why did I forget
we should have identified the threat
there
you
okay life is still okay I'm still up up
two pawns I can count
and the plan might be to play f4 and
then wrote d7 or just to flag him which
I would actually kind of feel bad about
but hmm that's chess
you
max villager almost beat I am
okay I can't pronounce that name Eric
something in exchange Spanish maybe
exchange Spanish to be more popular
and underestimated opening and this is a
three nights
okay let's go in for the kill but not
too quickly let's play it f4 first
and then it's very close to me rook d7
King e6 night c5
okay
the rook
push the pawn
hmm is he winning upon no he's not I'm
gonna do this
maybe is winning Lafon
thanks for the sub let's attack the
bishop and I'm gonna throw in this check
so I want to see where he moves the King
where's he going to flag he does
not flag
it's gonna play this but then when he
takes upon use defending d8 so let's
take the bishop
you
h3
for me
he flagged okay good game Mike can't
read GG I help an oboe finally caught me
online so I think thank you discovered
on YouTube well that's good to hear
thanks for the comments preciate that
from Italy nice I've never been to Italy
but I would love to go so I like Italian
food and the people seem nice anyway I'm
going to probably end things here I am
streaming from my Mac I have my PC as
well but my PC is not as powerful so
yeah my Mac does the heavy lifting
anyway thanks everyone for watching and
subbing and following do you want to
refresh here at some point I'll do kind
of some kind of celebration for the the
almost 3 3000 followers I need 10 more
followers for 3000 that's exciting so
probably in the next stream will be
I don't know if it's gonna be special
but it might be different thanks again
to toilet noggin the bit leader I'll see
everyone in the future and let me get
out of this tournament before I
accidentally start in another game uh
yeah bye guys